[Music]
12 year old singer Evy Claire teared up
after performing a touching tribute to
her late father on night 1 of the
America's Got Talent finale
Andy's dad died earlier this month after
losing his battle with colon cancer how
did you get through that performance I
mean I just prayed before that I would
that I would be able to like that and I
know my dad was there and so I mean from
my family from the audience what was the
significance of that particular song for
this finale that was my dad's favorite
song he'd always sing that and and that
would be the only song he was singing in
public well that my mom would let him
sing in public
yeah that was just kind of like a
tribute to him what hasn't meant not
only to be on this show and competing
and AGT but to share part of it with
your dad to have this great opportunity
with him and memories that we'll never
forget
have you given any thoughts that if you
do take this whole thing home what
you'll do with the million dollars we
had a solid plan before I was gonna use
the money so I go find a better cure for
my dad but now we don't know what to do
events truce maturities arrested
overturned
what you hope to inspire and other kids
who are maybe going through a similar
situation just know that God is on their
side he doesn't abandon us he did these
hard things don't happen because he
doesn't love us he does this because He
loves us he wants to make us stronger he
wants to prepare us for even harder
things down the road even though it
seems like this is the hardest thing
that could possibly happen it's it's
really all just preparation
[Music]